الا ليت الشباب يعود يوما فاخبره بما صنع
المشيب يبدو ان الشباب اقرب لان يعود من
اي وقت مضى بالفعل وبعد تجارب اجريت
لثلاثه اعوام على الفئران والخلايا
البشريه باحثون يكتشفون جينات متحوله في
مجموعه من المعمرين تساعد على تجديد شباب
القلب تلك الجينات يمكن ان تعيد عمر القلب
الى الوراء باكثر من عشره اعوام بحسب
الاختبارات على الفئران والنقطه الاهميه
استجابه الفئران المسنه التي تعاني مشكله
في القلب بشكل ايجابي الدراسه اجريت في
انابيب باختبار احتوت على خلايا القلب
بشريه جمعت من كبار السن يعانون مشاكل
القلبيه حاده ولعلى الطب التجديد من ابرز
التطورات العلميه التي يشهدها العالم
لمعالجه الشيخوخه وتشديد خلايا الجسم
[موسيقى]